Speaker 1: This is now completely beyond parody.
Mypillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell.
I know you're going to say, David, but you
did this story last year.
I know Mike Lindell, also known as Mike Pillow
or just pillow has knew very, very big.
Not just very big, but very, very big cyber
evidence, cyber evidence that is going to
blow the roof off of the 2020 election.
Now we're only, what, three and a half months
from the 2022 election, but he's still working
on 2020.
Listen to this.
And at this point, does anyone believe this?
I mean, the crowds at Trump rallies cheer
when he says this stuff, but do they even
believe it?
Speaker 2: I got news this morning that there
was a very big, big, big, big everybody.
Pieces of evidence, cyber evidence.
From the 2020 election that we didn't even
know before that.
Now we have it's it's I'm just so excited.
Validated validated multiple sources.
And we also felt from another source said
a completely different cyber guy.
Speaker 1: He seems almost bored by his own
blockbuster news.
He sounds kind of like he's over it.
Speaker 2: Found more evidence from the missile
data, which we have right up here in free
speech.
So all you horrible journalists out there
that are watching tonight.
You might want to take a look there and look
at what I'm talking about and get your cyber
guys ready.
There's more to come and it is very readable
and understandable.
Speaker 1: A sniffing, disheveled, uncomfortable
looking mike pillow making declarations that
even his co-host seems to be pretty damn skeptical
of now.
Would it be shocking to you to find out that
all of this new evidence comes from nest thermostats?
That would be a big shock, but apparently
nest thermostat.
So the new nexus of cyber criminality.
I'm genuinely curious about how long this
is going to go because we're almost at the
2022 midterms.
Could pillow keep going with this beyond the
2022 midterms?
What about 2024?
Like, there's no way that after 24 he would
say we're going to go back and reinstate Trump
from the 2020 election.
Right.
Like that.
That seems beyond even pillows ability to
take himself seriously.
I don't know the answer, but he's still invited
to the Trump rallies.
He still speaks there.
And at some point, the question has to become
he keeps if he keeps repeating it, is it because
people keep believing it and thinking that
this guy knows something when he knows nothing
at all?
Maybe like with Trump, it's more about the
followers than the person saying the stuff.
Strange, bizarre, unusual, and also comical,
quite frankly.
But the perfect touch here is that he just
seems bored.
He's like, I have very, very big evidence.
It's coming out soon.
This is like the biggest, most exciting thing.
And we're going to tell you, it's from, you
know, it's it's from Arizona and it's going
to just blow everything off.
It's going to overturn the election.
He couldn't be more bored with his own so-called
data.
All right.
The question I have is, how long will this
go on?
Will it go on beyond 2022?
Will it get all the way to 2024?
When will pillow end this madness?
Find me on Twitter at Pacman and let me know.
The David Pakman Show is different from other
shows, at least from some other shows.
We depend on the support of our audience for
our operation.
Meaning you can sign up at join pacman dot
com and become a
member and get the bonus show.
Oh, the bonus show.
Yeah.
And the commercial free audio and video streams
of the show and all of it.
And you can do it at a discount with the coupon
code.
Big Voting 22